what about what you said about uh
like um a woman's company doesn't do
anything
for you if there's no sex involved and
you get better company from a dog
that's not what i said i said a dog is
loyal if you want loyalty get a dog
i don't i don't have any interest in
hanging out with
with women just to you know do things
with them like unless i'm intimate with
them
what is the point i don't i just don't
have that interest now there's other
guys out there that would disagree with
me on that
and they want to have female friends but
they usually try to be friends with
these women because they want to bang
them
and i can promise you that this is
accurate and verifiable and true
on a balance of probabilities because in
almost every single case whenever i've
talked to a guy who's like
yes you know she's got these guy friends
that said fine take her phone
and then text them and say hey i'm horny
let's bang
and see what they do she's either gonna
freak out
or if he gets a chance to grab the phone
on a balance of probabilities the guy's
going to message back
and start engaging in conversations
about that because when men hang around
women that they're not having sex with
it's because they want to have sex with
them
it's generally not because they like to
hear about their basket weaving stories
or their well can they want to have sex
with them but also enjoy their company
even if it never leads to sex the way
they might enjoy the company of a man of
a guy
in my view from my position only if it's
a business transaction so
um i'm working on a project right now
and the
uh lead for one part of the project that
i'm working on is a woman
um i've had lunch with her twice um i've
had several phone calls with her
i've got a conference call coming up
very very soon
uh we've heard another uh partner in the
project
i have no trouble with that that's
absolutely fine but
i'm working on something i don't want to
sit back and have like
no offense irene i'm sure you're a smart
lady but i mean if you said to me hey
let's grab a coffee and sit down and
shoot the [ __ ]
i'm good no thanks
so why do you not no
i mean i don't mean this towards me but
like why do you feel this towards women
in general
because i don't find women particularly
interesting i find
the stuff that i want to do interesting
guys will go
and pretend to be friends with women
but it's because they want to have sex
with them primarily it's not because
they want to
pick their brain on their political
opinions or learn more about feminism
can there be exceptions to that i'm sure
there's some exceptions but on a bounce
of probabilities most guys want to bang
hot women that they're trying to be
friends with so
you've never been friends with somebody
with a woman
uh and like it was a really good trip
but i wanted to ban them
okay but let's say you couldn't bang
them let's say they were in a
relationship
you still friends with them like for a
while and it was a good friendship
no because you get frustrated after a
while guys guys hate being in the friend
zone see
this is the thing that women don't
understand about guys is
they think that you know when you friend
zone guys that everything's okay oh he's
my buddy you know you know he's my pal
you know we'll talk about stuff and
we'll shoot the [ __ ] and all that sort
of thing
but when they part ways he goes home
thinking about her
and she's thinking about chat she's
thinking
about somebody else it's it's
great behavior it's beta behavior and
let's say
let's say you should do a lot less of it
okay well let's say you're not friend
zoned let's say you are viewed as an
alpha male but sex is just not an option
and why should you be frustrated you can
just have sex with someone else
no
you're you're you're completely missing
the point so
what do i do in my spare time i go to
the dojo and i box i do krav maga
i'm a member of a supercar club i drive
fast cars with a bunch of friends of
mine
there's no women in any of those
scenarios there's yeah there are
no there are there are women in martial
arts
yeah okay so let's use that example so i
go to the dojo
and just before my class start the
instructor's with this um
girl and he's trying you know training
her and she's doing some uh striking
exercises
and she's got like there's nothing
behind it
i mean if i were to get into a uh round
of a
few fights you know like a couple of
three minutes rounds
it would be two hits it would be me
hitting her and her hitting the ground
not saying you're supposed to fight them
i'm saying women might have the same
interests with you not that you should
do krav maga with a girl right but it's
like the same thing going back to me
riding the leader bike
and hanging out with a chick that also
rides motorcycles but she's on a 250.
now i don't know if you know the
difference between a 250 and a liter
bike but it's like the difference
between
a bicycle and a ferrari
right she's just not going to be able to
keep up so i don't have much interest in
wanting to engage her
at the dojo with some striking skills
i'd rather work
you know directly with the instructor
and he comes up to my level
like when i do uppercuts he feels it
like he like
he feels the power when i watch the
girls doing it there's nothing behind it
so you're saying that the way you bond
with men is primarily doing physical
things and if you were to do the same
physical things with women it just
wouldn't
men do men do women talk that's okay
that's
that's the biggest difference between
men and women when men get together
we usually do stuff when women get
together it's over a glass of wine and
they kind of shoot the [ __ ] or they're
doing a book club or something like that
that's usually the biggest difference
between men and women is we like to do
stuff like when i get together with my
guys with a car club
we got the radios charges like a dozen
of us maybe two dozen of us
we have a destination in mind we're
egging each other on as we'll drive and
we're calling each other [ __ ] bags you
know on the radios
it's just you know it's just fun time
like that's what guys do and that's fine
and in some cases there's women there
sometimes my daughter comes along
sometimes i've got my ltr with me
sometimes i roll solo sometimes i bring
a friend
it doesn't matter like it's not like
women are excluded from it
it's just i would i would do those
things with a supercar club with the
dudes
okay how many how many women do you know
that have a 300 000
mclaren i don't know any okay well i
know about two dozen guys that have
a 300 000 mclaren you see my point right
like men and women have different
interests
how many shoes but you have not not very
many
how many hand makes you own one
one more than what i own
okay but you have interests that aren't
about that don't require
like um all this all this uh physical
kind of vigor
don't you or like like say
physical rigor sorry don't you have
don't you have some interest
where women could be more involved or
like like
what am i going to talk to women about
politics because when women talk
what do you talk to guys about
liberalism sorry
it's always about yeah like socialist
agenda feminism
patriarchy blah blah blah blah i don't
talk to women about politics it's
pointless
i can't even talk to half the men today
about politics because so many of them
are so feminized
all they're trying to do is white knight
and kiss the butts of these toxic
feminists right
okay so is it like so you have your ltr
you have your daughter like
maybe some women in your family and you
feel like you get whatever feminine
energy you want from there
including through talking and you just
like don't want anymore
yeah things you do i don't i don't live
under a rock or just hang around men
only just when i do things that i
want to choose to do that happen to be
fun they're
always involving other dudes
okay i'm not entirely sure what i
disagree with you about at this point
you don't disagree with anything you
just don't you just didn't like the tone
in my book you just didn't like some of
the conclusions because they didn't
resonate with you
it did resonate with me well you seem to
have a little bit of a problem with it
because i mean you know you went to my
website you fill out the sponsored
requests you paid me 200
to read that yeah
well i'm sure i'll have follow-up
questions but i don't know how quickly
i'll think of them
you